[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We have a very
special treat today.
We have Alaka Wali in
here to talk to us.
Alaka is a curator
of North American
anthropology at our
very own Field Museum.
She is also the
founding director
of the Center of Cultural
Understanding and Change,
which was founded in 1995.
Her research focuses on the
relationship between art
and the capacity for social
resilience, so something
that we really care
about here at Google.
And today she'll
be talking to us
about the repurposing of
century-old collection
to tell modern stories.
So please join me in welcoming
Alaka Wali today to talk.
[APPLAUSE]
ALAKA WALI: Thank you.
Well, if you all ever
need an anthropologist,
I'm ready to be
hired here at Google.
What a wonderful place.
What a great building.
We got a great tour with Joe.
And I'm really happy to be
here to talk with all of you
about the Field
Museum's newer projects.
I've been there
for about 20 years.
I should tell you that I'm not
your standard curator type.
I don't know if you all have
stereotyped notions of what
a curator is, but I'm not that.
I'm an applied anthropologist.
I've always, in my
whole career, been
interested in how we can use
anthropology to solve problems,
especially pressing problems
that face people today.
I work both here--
I do urban anthropology--
and I also work in
the Amazon, working
with indigenous communities
around issues of,
how we can engage people
to better conserve
the forests in which they live.
And here in Chicago, we
work with communities
in all of the different
neighborhoods around Chicago
as well in thinking about,
again, their place here.
Then how to make a better
quality of life that
includes caring for
our environment,
but also what it takes to
make a better quality of life.
So that's part of what I've
been doing at the Field Museum,
but I'm also the person since
2010 who's taken care of
or been responsible for our
North American anthropology
collections.
And so that's what I'm going
to talk to you about today.
When I came to the
museum, there was really
a sense at the
museum that we needed
to do more than just exhibits
of dinosaurs and mummies.
We love our dinosaurs.
We love our mummies.
But we have a lot more to
offer than just dinosaurs
and mummies.
And so we really want
to begin to think
about, how can we
use our collections?
How can we make them relevant to
today, to contemporary issues?
So that's what I've kind of been
thinking about and working on
since I became the curator
of this collection, the North
American collection.
So that's what I'm going
to talk to you about.
And then hopefully we'll
just have a dialogue
as well about some of that,
or about any of the other work
we do at the Field Museum.
So the Field Museum, it's this
century-plus-old institution
in Chicago.
It's actually the fourth
largest natural history
museum in the world in terms
of the size of our collections.
We have over 30 million
between the specimens,
the natural history specimens,
and over a million artifacts
in the anthropology collection.
So we are a world class
institution, if you will.
And so we do have all
of these collections.
Here's Stanley Field
Hall with the--
you can just see Sue in the
back there, our elephant.
So it's a classic Greek,
evocative of the temple
of the museum kind
of institution.
And we have these
amazing collections
at the Field Museum.
I'm just going to focus on the
anthropology collections that
speak to the heritage
of the world in terms
of who we are as human beings.
Who are we as human beings?
What do we do?
What have we done?
So those two objects
I just showed you
were from the North
American collection.
This is a sword and
shield from Africa.
This is an amazing
sort of armor,
sort of vest also from Africa.
This is from South America.
And these are our
bronze sculptures
that I'm going to talk
about in a minute.
So we have this
amazing collection.
Every single object, I think,
in our anthropology collection--
some of them are
not as beautiful.
I gave you some
beauty shots there.
But some of them are
not that beautiful,
but they're still amazing for
the stories they can tell.
And the problem is
that the stories
we had been telling in the
old halls in the old museum
have been problematic stories.
And some of our halls--
like this one is the North
American Indian Hall--
still look like they're stuck
in the 1930s or 1900s even,
image of what a natural history
museum should look like.
And so that's a problem
because science changes.
And we're a scientific
institution.
And if we're going to
tell relevant stories,
we have to keep up to
date with both the way
we talk about and
represent culture
and what we know about
human social behavior.
And we have to be able to
do it in a compelling way.
So that's the kind of
problem that's confronting us
right now, is we think about
how to transform the museum
and how to repurpose
our collections.
Because they are so amazing,
they can tell powerful stories.
So how do we do that?
How do we make them tell?
How do we get them to tell
the stories that they're
capable of telling?
So today I want to talk to you
about three different examples
of how we're starting to
think about repurposing
the collections to tell
contemporary stories
and talk about the
Malvina Hoffman
sculptures, the bronzes.
Talk about collaborating
with contemporary artists.
And then talk about our native
North America collection.
So the Malvina
Hoffman sculptures,
this is a new exhibit that
we just opened in January.
It will be in its current
location for about another two
years, or a year and a half.
So please come see it.
And this is an exhibition that
uses these bronze sculptures.
There's 104 of them that
were made by an artist named
Malvina Hoffman.
She was a student of Rodin.
And she was commissioned
by the Field Museum
to make these sculptures for
the 1933 Century of Progress
World's Fair, that was following
the big World's Fair in 1893,
was the next big World's
Fair that Chicago hosted.
And the Field Museum
directors and the curators
wanted to have a big
splash at that fair.
And so they decided to
open two new exhibitions.
One was a hall of
evolution, and the other one
was going to be called
the Races of Mankind.
And what they wanted was
to show what at that time
was considered state of
the art thinking about race
and the way in which we can
categorize human beings.
But rather than just have
an exhibit that basically
looks like this, they decided--
and they had been for a
while, the Field Museum
directors and curators,
had been using artists
in making the dioramas.
I think many of you might be
familiar with the dioramas.
A lot of those dioramas,
the backgrounds
are made by famous local artists
here in Chicago of that time.
So they were familiar
with using art
to convey scientific
information.
And in the case of
this Races of Mankind,
they decided to go all out
and work with Malvina Hoffman.
But the message of
the exhibition was--
if you think about what
the thinking around race
was in the 1930s,
that was kind of
like the height of the
eugenicist movement in both
the United States and then
reverberating back to Europe,
and think about Hitler.
Where did he get his ideas?
A lot of his ideas
were influenced
by scientists, or
so-called scientists,
who were promoting this
eugenicist view of race
and racial typologising.
And the fundamental underlying
assumption of the typologising
is that we humans can be divided
into these categories called
races based solely
on the way we look,
so our phenotypic variation.
And to sort of like
say, OK, well--
and then the great
debate was around,
well, where do you
make these lines of who
fits into what category?
And so some scientists
of that time
argue that there were these
four broad categories.
There was the negroid, the
mongoloid, the caucasoid,
and then the Native
American or indigenous type.
Some said three types.
But then other scientists,
such as the ones
at the Field
Museum, said there's
a lot more physical variation.
So we have more types.
And so in this exhibition
that they created,
they want it to show the
varieties of human typologies
that they saw.
And basically, their typology
was based on geography.
So here is a map
that was produced out
of that exhibition.
And you can sort of see-- can
you see that it's color coded?
Different types belong in
different parts of the world.
It's not based on science.
It's based on an ideology
rather than a science.
So the ideology that underlies
this way of thinking about
physical variation
among humans is
that these differences
matter, and that in addition
to sort of drawing a
line between how we look,
the categories of
race, those categories
correspond to
differences in behavior.
That's what's so pernicious
about this kind of what
we call scientific racism.
Because it was the association
of behavior with the way
you look.
So folks who had thick
lips and big noses
were immediately
characterized as behaving
in a way that was
inferior to folks
who had fine Greek noses and
aquiline features, if you will.
So that kind of thinking
about the association
between behavior
and looks is what
has been the insidiousness of
race and racial typologising.
So by 1969, the thinking around
race among anthropologists,
and I think among scientists
in general for the most part,
had changed because of the
revolution with the DNA
discoveries.
And so once people started
doing genetic analysis of human
variation, as you
all probably know,
what we found is that you
cannot categorize people
into subcategories.
We're all one species.
We're all homo sapiens sapiens.
There isn't a way in
which you can say, well,
hair type and nose
shape and lips all
correspond to make this type
different from that type.
Genetically, that's
a bunch of nonsense.
And so knowing
that, the curators
of the 1960s at the
Field Museum decided
that the exhibition Races of
Mankind should be de-installed.
There was also, by that
time, as you probably know--
probably didn't live
through that time,
looking at all of you--
there was in the 1960s, with
the Civil Rights Movement
in this country, and with
independence movements
globally, there was
a kind of a sense
of protest against the whole
issues around race and racism.
The anti-racist work was
starting to build in that time.
And the idea that you
could depict people
into these kinds of typologies
had become pretty offensive.
And actually, this map, if
I can go back for a second,
this was a map made
with our sculptures.
Can you see the sculptures here?
These are all the sculptures.
I'm going to show you
better photos in a minute.
This was made by
Hammond, the map company,
and used in schools
around the country.
So it's very widely distributed.
And this African American poet--
Amiri Baraka, or LeRoi
Jones, he was known--
saw the map, wrote a letter
to the Field Museum, and said,
you should cease
and desist in using
this kind of racist material.
And so the Field Museum was
getting a lot of pressure
around the exhibition,
although it
was a very popular exhibition
because people really
loved the sculptures.
So if you come to the museum
and see them, you'll see why.
The sculptures themselves
have a very compelling quality
to them.
They're-- Malvina Hoffman as
a student of Rodin knew how
to sculpt in bronze.
In fact, the original
idea of the curators
was that these
figures of the races
would all be plaster casts.
And she convinced them that they
should be these bronze statues.
And she was in love with
the human form as well.
So her sculptures are
all of beautiful people.
Look at this guy.
I mean, you know.
And even when they depict
what seems so exotic to us,
people have this quality of
dignity in her sculptures.
And so the sculptures
have remained popular.
And when I came to
the Field Museum,
I fell in love with
the sculptures.
Even though I knew about
the kind of problematic past
of the exhibition and the
scientific or pseudoscientific
thinking that had
informed that exhibition,
I couldn't see how we would
just relegate those sculptures
to the closet or
de-accession them.
Because they've had
such a relationship
to the history of the
museum, and because they're
so compelling.
So we were thinking about, how
do we tell this story again?
How do we bring the
sculptures out of the closet
and tell a modern story?
And we also wanted
to honor Malvina,
one of the very
few women sculptors
of her time who did this
massive amount of work.
She made 104 of these
bronzes in three years.
And she traveled the world.
She was in India.
She went there to sculpt
people from living examples.
It's a long story.
I'm not going to go into it.
But it's amazing, her story.
So we didn't want to
just ignore the value
of these compelling,
beautiful sculptures.
We wanted to use them.
So we have now made
a new exhibition
that is called
Looking at Ourselves,
Rethinking the Sculptures
of Malvina Hoffman.
And in that exhibit, we now
talk about what we know today
about race and racism and
how the thinking around race
has continued to
persist and continues
to impact our lives today.
So here what you see here
are some of the busts
that she made.
And with the busts,
we talk about what
is wrong with the
way that we have
learned to think about race.
And the problem is, as much as I
can say to you that there is no
such thing as race
biologically--
it doesn't make
sense, et cetera--
it's so ingrained in the way
we think about each other.
It's so ingrained in how we
judge each other physically,
phenotypically, if you will.
So it's really
hard to get people
to stop thinking about it in the
way that we've been kind of--
we've absorbed into the
way we think about race.
And so we're hoping that
in connecting these 1933
sculptures to
Black Lives Matter,
we can start to think
about that deep hold
that the ideology
of race has on us,
has continued to
have this insidious
effect on the structure
of our societies.
And as much as we would like to
think that the concept is dead,
it's not dead.
And its consequences live on.
So that's one part
of the exhibit.
That's one way that we're trying
to think about, how do you--
because the sculptures are
so inviting, so compelling,
how can we use them to
tell this newer story?
And then these are
these full figure
bronzes that she also made.
So she made busts, and she
made these full figure bronzes.
And what's so cool about
these is that she didn't just
make sort of the
racial typology things
that the curators wanted.
And in fact, she was arguing
with the curators all the time.
She made people.
And in her notes,
she kept records
with her husband of
who these people were.
And so we have the stories
of some of these individuals.
And in many cases--
in almost all cases--
she put some cultural
markers on them.
And whether it was in the
clothes they're wearing
or their adornment or the
things they're doing--
can you see this guy
is climbing a tree?
This is southern India.
He's a toddy palm.
He's getting toddy hot-- which
is a syrup from the toddy palm.
And there's video
footage from her travels.
So it's all a really very,
very deep collection.
And the stories of these
people are really amazing.
This guy here on the surfboard
is Sargent Kahanamoku.
And he and his
family were the ones
who were responsible for
the popularity of surfing
in the 1950s.
His brother Duke
traveled to California
and was really important in
terms of popularizing surfing.
People are not what they seem.
So the guy in the middle
in the kind of yoga
pose, she made him
pose like that.
He was a Cambridge
scholar that she
met in England or
Paris and generally
a very dapper dresser.
So there's a lot of
problematics to this collection.
But I think we can
tell a good story.
And with the full
figure stories,
we try to tell the story
of how our behavior isn't
defined by how we look.
That you cannot associate
behavior with the way you look.
So folks who look a certain way,
think of all the stereotypes
you know.
I like to use the example
of the blond bimbo.
Blond women are often
characterized as dumb.
So we know that's
not true, right?
I mean, I don't have
to go into the obvious.
But people who look like this--
these are the San people from
the Kalahari Desert, often
characterized as our
Stone Age ancestors,
as the people who are the most
primitive of the primitive.
Well, these people
have a history.
The San were, in
fact, for a long time,
they were agricultural folks.
They had cattle.
And then they were
pushed off their lands.
They end up in the
Kalahari Desert.
They figure out how to live
in the Kalahari Desert.
They figure out that to
live in the Kalahari Desert,
you actually can
live pretty well.
And what their life is like
today in the Kalahari Desert
before they were
colonized and pushed again
under reservations--
they were, by hunting
and gathering nuts,
they had enough food to live.
And they only had to work
maybe two hours a day, if that.
And their time is
their own to set.
And so they have all this
time where they tell stories.
They dance.
They have a rich
life, cultural life.
Like you guys at Google.
Because you don't have to
work all the time either.
No, I'm just kidding.
You can set your
own time, right?
So in a way, people realize
the wisdom of this lifestyle
that the San have.
And when anthropologists
started telling this story
about the Kalahari San and
that they're not so primitive
as we like to think, I don't
think people believed us
for a long time.
And then people did actual
nutritional studies and so on
and found that that was true.
And then there's a third
part of the exhibit
where we talk about
Malvina's story,
and how she had the courage
to stand up to the curators
and to use her art.
So her art really
subverts the narrative
that the curators wanted
to tell about human beings
and our physical variation.
And in the end, the
sculptures, because of the way
she made them into
portraits of real people,
and because they're
so compelling,
we can bring them out.
We can tell this
new story with them
and confront the problematic way
in which they were used before.
Talk about that, not hide that.
But also then say,
what do we do today?
What do we know today?
And how do we think about
race and racism today?
So that's one way we
repurposed the collection.
Then I became the curator of
this North American collection.
And by chance, I
happened to meet
Maria Pinto, who's a fashion
designer right here in Chicago.
She is known because
she designed dresses
for Michelle Obama back in
the day and for Oprah Winfrey
and so on.
And I thought it
would be fun to have
her come and look
at our collection
and think about what--
see what she saw in the
collection as an artist.
And so we took her
into the collections.
And I thought she
was going to be
interested in these
kinds of things.
We have these
beautiful silk kimonos.
To me, that's what fashion
is kind of stereotypically--
I didn't know anything
about fashion.
And it turns out she wasn't.
She liked them.
But that's not what
she was interested in.
She was more interested
in things like this
that we had in our collection.
This is a mask from Brazil.
And what interested
her was the way
that people around the world
used materials and used
natural materials in these
super innovative ways to create,
and how careful
they were to craft,
how much attention they paid
to the actual stitching.
Because she's a very
detail-oriented person.
And she's really
interested in her clothes.
So I'm wearing a Maria
Pinto, just because I
have to talk this evening.
But I think the camera
man noticed, right?
Immediately noticed
that it has this collar.
She's interested in
not just the look
of things, but in
how they're made,
and the materials that are used.
So she became very
excited by these things.
And she ended up--
she had to choose 25 out
of the hundreds of objects
that she saw to put
in her exhibition.
And what we've been
doing is we asked
her to choose her own designs,
clothing that she had made,
to put in with our collections.
And to sort of bring
that perspective
of an artist aesthetic to
looking at our collection.
So it's a way of bringing
out our collections
and letting people see them
through the eyes of an artist,
rather than through
the curatorial eye.
And then actually stopping
to look and see, what is this
made of?
And isn't it-- would you wear
this today, the Inuit raincoat?
It looks so modern, right?
It looks like something
you could wear today.
And it has this kind of
appeal that's enduring.
And her own designs,
that kind of translucency
that you see in the Inuit
raincoat or coat made out
of seal intestine, is
something that she had been--
she wasn't directly inspired
to make that by this,
but there's a resonance there.
AUDIENCE: So the coat--
when is the coat from?
ALAKA WALI: The coat is from
probably the late 19th century.
AUDIENCE: How was
it made out of seal?
ALAKA WALI: It's made
out of seal intestine.
Yeah, waterproof, right?
You know, here's the thing.
People-- yes, everything
is functional.
So when people make stuff, they
want to make it functional.
But there's always-- in
our collections, what
you begin to see--
and this is what
has been so powerful for me--
is this aesthetic element
to everything people make.
To make it functional,
they didn't
have to trim it with
these beautiful--
right?
They didn't have to do that.
Or seams or kind of pay
attention to any of that.
So think about what that
says about human creativity
and why people want to have
aesthetic things around them
all the time.
And what have we lost if
we don't pay attention
to that sense of aesthetics?
That's the art and
social resilience
thing that I'm working on.
So here's another example.
And what was fun about
doing this exhibition was,
in addition to just putting
the objects with her designs,
we told the stories
of how they were made.
And we didn't put
labels because I
didn't want to have
her instillation marred
by didactic label copy.
So instead, we did
that on a touch screen.
And so you could touch
each one of these,
including her garments.
And you could see the
story about that piece
and what we knew about it.
And then sort of in that same
vein, but now more recently,
I've been working with
Native American artists
because we have about 75,000
objects from native North
America as anthropology objects.
If we look at our
archeology collections,
there's over 250,000 from
native North America.
And so it's a really
daunting responsibility
to think about, how do you use--
how do you bring
that out responsibly
and in a way that
respects native voice?
Because at this
point, I think we
at the Field Museum
feel that just having
a sort of curatorial
voice telling the story,
it's not as rich, and it's not
as accurate even, as including
the voice of the
people whose heritage
this collection represents.
So again, the question
I was faced with
was, well, which people?
And who?
So I have selected
to work with artists
from the native community.
And today, native North
American contemporary artists,
that scene is booming.
It's exploding.
There's so much rich work that
native artists are producing
right now.
So there's like
no end to what we
can do working with
Native American artists.
And again, it's their
unique perspective.
It's not a community or
a collective perspective,
but it is collective and
individual at the same time.
And so the first one we work
with was Bunky Echo Hawk.
He's a Pawnee artist.
The reason I got
interested in him
was because I found
out that he was asked
by Nike to design Nike wear.
They have a line called
M7, which is specifically
for Native American
athletes or people
of Native American heritage.
It's a really cool
seventh generation thing.
And they actually asked native
artists to design the line.
So he was one of the first
to do that with them.
And so he came.
And like Maria Pinto, he
was selecting objects.
He chose objects pretty
much from the Pawnee,
and then his mom is
from from Yakima peoples
in Washington state.
And this guy, he's not
even 40 yet, I don't think.
And his father is a very
famous native rights lawyer,
Walter Echo Hawk.
But Bunky knows so much about
Pawnee cultural heritage.
And so he was looking at the
objects in our collection
and telling us,
oh, this is this,
and this is what that means.
And so we learned a tremendous
amount from working with him.
And then in his case, again,
he does painting on acrylic,
using acrylic on canvas.
And he selected I
think about 20 objects
and paired them with his work.
And here can you
see that the paint--
he was inspired to make this
painting, out with the old,
in with the new.
I love that, because
when he saw this dress,
which is in our collection--
and that's probably late--
this is a Ghost Dance dress,
from the time of the Ghost
Dance, late 19th century.
And then see these?
These are buffalo horn spoons,
that the actual ones also
were in the exhibit.
These are-- he fell in
love with these spoons made
of buffalo horn.
Look at how-- that's
what I was saying.
You It's just a spoon.
But look at how beautiful it
is, how well crafted it is.
And he was like,
thinking-- and he
says, think about what it meant
to eat with a spoon like that.
How would your food taste?
How would you think about
who you are, having made
and knowing who
made such a spoon?
And then think about what
we eat with today, plastic.
Or even if we're
using stainless steel.
It doesn't have that power.
It doesn't tell you
something about yourself,
when you don't have that
same kind of aesthetic
to the quality of
your everyday life.
And so for me, that was
a very powerful moment.
And that painting is powerful
because he's basically saying,
are we throwing out the
old in favor of the new?
And what does that
mean when we do that?
And here's another one.
This is a very popular painting.
You can go on his
website and get
prints of this one, the
Yoda in the headgear.
It's called "If
Yoda was an Indian."
And Bunky came to the
opening of the exhibit,
and all these kids saw
him and immediately wanted
to have their photo
taken with him.
And it was wonderful
kind of a moment there.
So now, right now
at the Field Museum,
we have two new exhibitions
that are just opened October 29.
And they're two
contemporary native artists.
One is Ronda Holy Bear.
She's a Lakota artist.
And the other is Chris Pappan.
And he is a Chicago
urban Indian,
but he's enrolled in the Kanza
tribe out in Oklahoma now.
They used to be Kansas.
And that's where the name
for the state comes from.
And he's also part Osage.
And so Rhonda does this
incredible bead work.
She taught herself how
to bead and to carve.
And Chris is a
ledger artist, which
is a narrative tradition
that comes from the Plains
Indians, where there was always
a long tradition of drawing
on hide or rock art
among the Plains Indians.
And then when they became
confined to reservations
or imprisoned on forts
in the late 19th century,
they got access to paper.
And they were making
these paper drawings
on paper called ledger art.
Often it was ledger books.
And so he calls himself a
21st century ledger artist.
He's reviving that tradition.
Here's Rhonda with the people
who gave us the initial--
they live in Chicago.
Some of her figures, some
of her older figures.
And then her story
is really cool
because she grew
up here in Chicago
and used to come to the
Field Museum all the time
and was inspired
by the collections
to start making her
figures, her dolls.
And did a lot of research
in our collection
so that she could make
accurate representations of--
you have to come see the
exhibit because her work is
pretty spectacular.
And again, some of
our-- you can see
where some of her
inspiration comes from.
Look at these.
This is 1893.
And with Chris, we did
something really different.
This is Chris.
This is his drawing that we
purchased for the museum.
And we purchased this one too.
I showed you that
old hall, right?
Remember I showed
you in the beginning
with the mannequins and
the faceless mannequins?
That hall is the
hall that is the last
of the permanent
halls that has never
been changed since the 1950s.
And we are about to begin the
process of redoing that hall.
We want to-- we're in the hunt
for money to redo the hall
and rethink how
we're going to do it.
But in the meantime,
we thought, why not
have Chris's exhibition be
an intervention in that hall?
Why not have him
comment through his art
on the representation
of native peoples
from this moment in our past?
And you don't have to say a lot.
When you see his--
these are kind of
reproductions of his work.
And then he made these
especially as decals
to put on the cases.
You don't have to say a lot.
For people to stop and look
and see things differently.
And I don't know if you
can see this back here.
This is a drawing he
did of a powwow chair.
And there's a collection for
Mark, like a fake catalog card
here.
So he's got a really
great sense of humor.
And there's a lot
of his drawings
that have this kind
of wry sense of humor,
as well as these
interventions on the cases.
And then he got excited
to do this with us
so he was inspired
to do something
he'd never done before, which
is to make a multimedia piece.
So that's on that screen
in the middle of the hall,
is this piece that
he did with two
of his collaborators, Adam Sings
in the Timber and Santiago X.
Adam is a film videographer, and
then Santiago X is a musician.
And so they came together, and
they found a 1894 Thomas Edison
silent film, one of
the very first films
that Edison ever made
was of native peoples.
He's calling it "The
Buffalo Dance," which
he found these people
in the Wild West Show,
a Buffalo Bill show.
And he got them to a studio,
and he made this silent film.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So Chris is commenting on
these old representations
of native peoples,
both in our hall
and in the way Americans have
thought about native peoples.
And they start deliberately
distorting the film.
I don't know if we're
going to see that.
But also superimposing these
images from contemporary times
to say, native peoples
are still here.
Native peoples are thriving.
They haven't disappeared.
Year They're not some
relic of your imagination,
some distortion version
of what they are today.
And so I think--
and here is the last
scene in the film.
It's also [INAUDIBLE]
of the current protest
right now that's
going on in North
Dakota against the pipeline,
the Dakota Access Pipeline.
How many of you are familiar
with what's going on there?
Yeah.
Good.
That's good.
And so I think--
I hope I've been
able to show you
that you can repurpose the past.
You can use our
incredible collections
to tell stories that
are relevant today
that concern all of us.
Nothing can be more important
than thinking about race,
right?
It affects all of us today.
We have to think about it.
How do we do it?
What is our job in our museum
to help people think about it?
Native peoples are here with us.
They have a lot to
teach us about what
we should value in life.
Why should we value
water over oil?
That's what that
protest was about.
So I think listening
to them, thinking
about what they
have created for us,
why is it important to
make stuff beautiful?
Why is that important
for human beings
to make things beautiful?
Listening to that,
thinking about that,
is a great part of how we
can begin to bring people
into dialogue with
each other and
with our amazing collections.
So thank you, and
thanks to our staff.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]